[Music]
in former times when the coast was less
people than now a boat's crew landed at
nook
they found no people and traversed the
fjord to kengursunek
halfway up to the east of cornoc near
kangusak they came upon a large house
but on getting closer to it they did not
know what to make of the people seeing
that they were not collate
in this manner they had quite
unexpectedly come across the first
kaflunak settlers
these likewise for the first time saw
the natives of the country and treated
them kindly and civilly but the
greenlanders nevertheless feared them
and made for their boats
when the boat and its crew returned from
their summer trip to the fjord they told
their countrymen all about their
encounter with the foreigners and many
of them now travelled up to see them
many boats having thus reached
kangarsunek they now began to have
intercourse with the kahlunate seeing
that they were well disposed towards
them later on in the summer many more
kalachit arrived and the foreigners
began to learn their language
at caposilic a kaflunak and kalachit it
is said became such fast friends that
they would not be separated but were
constantly together
they tried to excel each other at
different games and feats of dexterity
and their countrymen on both sides were
greatly diverted as lookers on but being
both first-rate archers their arrows
always fell side by side one day the
kaflunak said come let us climb up that
hill but first we will stretch a skin
for a target to aim at then we will try
which of us can hit the mark he who
fails shall be thrown down the precipice
and the other remained the conqueror the
clathlete answered no i will not agree
to that because we are friends and none
of us shall perish but the kaflunak
persisted so long that his own
countrymen at last said well let him be
thrown down as it is his only will
and they climbed the mountain together
accompanied by a crowd of spectators
the kaflunak was the first to shoot but
altogether failed then the kalahet came
in for his turn and pierced the skin in
the center according to his own desire
the kaflunak was hurled down the
precipice and his countrymen only
thought it served him right for having
thus recklessly pledged his life
[Music]
from that day until the present this
mountain has been called the shooting
place
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv a
question a lot of people ask in the
comments is where do i find the sources
for voices of the past well a lot of
them i find using the internet archive
an amazing online resource with huge
amounts of rare texts in full and so my
recommendation on magellan tv this week
is a great new documentary called the
bookmakers which celebrates the history
of books and most importantly features
that fantastic website pretty heavily
it's a great exploration of the joy of
reading a good book and how they've
influenced the course of history and of
course magellan have more than 3 000
other documentaries to check out too
it's a sort of netflix for documentaries
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
about the 10th glass in the afternoon
the african galley which was sailing
ahead of us later wait for us making the
signal of land in sight
and so when we came up with her we asked
what they had seen
on this we were answered that they had
all very distinctly seen a low and
flattish island lying away to starboard
about five and a half miles off to the
northwards and westwards the necessary
information was given to the captain who
was a stern and to the land the name of
pash island because it was discovered by
us on easter day
[Music]
there was great rejoicing among the
people and everyone hoped that this low
land might prove to be a four token of
the coastline of the unknown southern
continent
as we had seen smoke ascending in
several places from which it might be
reasonably concluded that the
aforementioned island although it may be
shown to be sandy and baron has
nevertheless human inhabitants now
therefore the president moved that it
would be culpable to proceed in a
careless and negligent manner and that
we should stand off for tonight with our
ships and that on the arrival of
daylight we send close into the land to
well-manned shallows and show all
friendliness towards the inhabitants
endeavouring to see and inquire what
they wear or make use of either as
ornaments for other purposes and whether
any refreshments in the way of green
stuff fruit or beasts can be procured by
barter
[Music]
the weather was very variable with
thunder sheet lightning and showers
during before noon captain bauman
brought an easter islander on board
together with his craft in which he had
come off close to the ship from the land
he was quite nude without the slightest
covering for that which modesty shrinks
from revealing this hapless creature
seemed to be very glad to behold us and
showed the greatest wander at the build
of our ship
he took special notice of the tortness
of our spars the stoutness of our
rigging and running gear the sails the
guns which he felt all over with minute
attention and with everything else that
he saw
especially when the image of his own
features was displayed before him in a
mirror seeing the witch he started
suddenly back and then looked towards
the back of the glass apparently in the
expectation of discovering there to be
the cause of the apparition
in the morning we proceeded with three
boats and two shallops manned by 134
persons all armed with musket pistols
and cutlass
after thus disposing our forces we
marched forward a little to make room
for some of the people who were behind
that they might fall in with the ranks
quite unexpectedly and to our great
astonishment four or five shots were
heard in our rear together with a
vigorous shout of its time it's time
fire
on this as in a moment more than 30
shots were fired and the indians being
thereby amazed and scared took to flight
leaving 10 or 12 dead besides the
wounded after a little while the
assistant pilot of the ship came up to
me saying that he with six other men was
the hindmost of the party that one of
the natives laying hold of the muzzle of
his piece to snatch it from him he
struck a blow and further that another
indian had attempted to strip the jacket
off one of the simon and that some of
the natives seeing our men resist picked
up stones using threatening gestures as
if to pelt us with them
after the astonishment and terror of the
natives were somewhat delayed on their
seeing that our hostilities were not
persisted in they were given to know by
signs that the victims had threatened to
make an assault on us by stone throwing
what the form of worship of these people
comprises we were not able to gather any
full knowledge of owing to the shortness
of our stay among them we noticed only
that they kindle fire in front of
certain remarkably tall stone figures
they set up and thereafter squatting on
their heels with heads bowed down they
bring the palms of their hands together
and alternately raise and lower them at
first these stone figures caused us to
be filled with wonder for we could not
understand how it was possible that
people who were destitute of heavy or
thick timber and also of stout cordage
out of which to construct gear had been
able to erect them
nevertheless some of these statues were
a good 30 feet in height and broad in
proportion this perplexity ceased
however with the discovery on removing a
piece of the stone that they were formed
out of clay or some other kind of rich
earth and that small smooth flints had
been stuck over afterwards which are
fitted very closely and neatly to each
other so as to make up the semblance of
a human figure
moreover one saw reaching downwards from
the shoulders a slight elevation or
prominence which represented the arms
for all the statues seemed to convey the
idea that they were hung about with a
long robe from the neck right down to
the soles of the feet
they have on the head a basket heaped up
with flint's painted white deposited in
it
[Music]
the country to which i have given the
name the arctic highlands is situated in
the northeast corner of baffin's bay
and towards the extremities is reduced
to nothing it is bounded on the south by
an immense barrier of mountains covered
with ice this barrier is impassable and
in many places the solid ice extends for
several miles into the sea from the
precipices from which it is connected
[Music]
origin of the arctic highlanders is a
question as of yet involved in peculiar
obscurity
they exist in a corner of the world by
far the most secluded which has yet been
discovered and have no knowledge of
anything but that which originates or is
found in their own country
nor do they have any tradition how they
came to this spot or from whence they
came having until the moment of our
arrival believed themselves to be the
only inhabitants of the universe and
that all the rest of the world was a
mass of ice
it is generally believed by the natives
of south greenland that they are
themselves descended from a nation in
the north and the moment they were
discovered our guide exclaimed these are
eskimo these are our fathers
it was believed that the northern was
the most ancient or most original
language
the similarity of the language proves
that they are the same people and it
appears most probable that south
greenland has been peopled from the
north and that the northern parts of
baffin's bay have been in the same
manner originally peopled from america
[Music]
the arctic highlanders did not worship
the sun moon stars or any image or any
living creature
when asked what the sun or moon was for
they said to give light they had no
knowledge or idea how they came into
being or of a future state but said that
when they died they would be put into
the ground
having fully ascertained that this man
had no idea of a supreme being i
proceeded to inquire if he believed in
an evil spirit but he could not be made
to understand what it meant
the word angercock which means a
conjurer or sorcerer was then pronounced
to him in the south greenland eskimo
language
he said they had many of them that it
was in their power to raise a storm or
make a calm and to drive off seals or
bring them that they learned this art
from older angercocks when young that
they were afraid of them but they had
generally won in every family
when this man was told that there was an
omnipotent omnipresent and invisible
being who had created the sea and land
and all therein he showed much surprise
and eagerly asked where he lived when
told that he was everywhere he was much
alarmed and became very impatient to get
away
when told that there was a future state
and another world he said that a wise
man who had lived long before his time
had said that they were to go to the
moon but that it was not now believed
and that none of the others knew
anything of this history they believed
however that birds and other living
creatures came from the moon
although there is certainly no proof
whatever that these people have any idea
of a supreme being or of a spirit good
or bad the circumstances of their having
conjurous and of their going to the moon
after death or of nature to prevent any
conclusion from being drawn to that
effect especially as it must be evident
that our knowledge of their language was
too imperfect to obtain the whole of
their ideas on the subject
[Music]
[Music]
in the days long past when i was a very
little boy a vessel came to fitianga
our tribe was living there at the time a
vessel came there and when our old men
saw the ship they said it was a
a god and the people on board were
strange beings
the ship came to anchor and the boats
pulled on shore
as our old men looked at the manner in
which they came on shore the rowers
pulling with their backs to the bows of
the boat the old people said yes it is
so these people are goblins
their eyes are at the back of their
heads they pull on shore with their
backs to the land to which they are
going
when these goblins came on shore we the
children and women took notice of them
but we ran away from them into the
forest and the warriors alone stayed in
the presence of these goblins
but to some of the goblins stayed some
time and did not do evil to our braves
we came back one by one and gazed at
them and we stroked their garments with
our hands and we were pleased with the
whiteness of their skin and the blue
eyes of some of them
these goblins began to gather oysters
and we gave some fish and fern root to
them and as we saw that these goblins
were eating fish and cockles we were
startled and said perhaps they are not
goblins like the maori goblins
we and the women gathered stones and
grass of all sorts and gave these to the
goblins
some of the stones they liked and put
them into their bags the rest they threw
away and when we gave them the grass and
the branches of trees they stood and
talked to us or they uttered the words
of their language perhaps they were
asking questions and as we did not know
their language we laughed and these
goblins also laughed so we were pleased
[Music]
the warriors and old men of our tribe
sat in silence and gazed at these
goblins now some of the goblins had
walking sticks which they carried about
with them and when we arrived at the
bare dead trees where the shags roost at
night and have their nests the goblins
lifted the walking sticks up and pointed
them at the birds and in a short time
thunder was heard to crash and a flash
of lightning was seen
and a shag fell from the trees and we
children were terrified and fled and
rushed into the forest and left the
goblins all alone
they laughed and waved their hands to us
and in a short time the bravest of us
went back to where the goblins were and
handled the bird and saw that it was
dead
but what had killed it
our old people waited in suspicion and
went back to the settlement as also did
the goblins we were now at quiet and
peace with them and they gave us some of
the food they had brought on shore with
them
after the ship had been lying at anchor
some time some of our warriors went on
board and saw many things there
when they came on shore they gave our
people an account of what they had seen
this made many of us desirous to go and
see the home of the goblins when we got
on board the ship we were welcomed by
the goblins whom our warriors answered
in our language
we sat on the deck of the ship where we
were looked at by the goblins who with
their hands stroked our mats and the
hair of the heads of us children at the
same time they made much gabbling noise
in talking
they held up some garments and showed
them to us touching hours at the same
time so we gave them our mats for their
mats to which some of our warriors said
ka pai
which words were repeated by some of the
goblins at which we laughed and were
joined in the laugh by the goblins
one of our tribe was killed by the
goblins who first came to fitianga this
man was a noted thief and took a dog
skin mat to sell to the goblins
there were five of them at the stern of
the canoe and four in the bow and this
thief was with those in the stern when
they got alongside of the ship the
goblin who collected shells flowers tree
blossoms and stones was looking over the
side he held up the end of a garment
which he would give in exchange for the
dog skin mat belonging to this noted
thief
so the thief waved with his hand to the
goblin to let some of it down into the
canoe which the goblin did
and as the goblin let some of it down
into the canoe the thief kept pulling it
towards him when the thief had got a
long length of the goblin's garment
before him and beckoned with his hand to
the man to give the dogskin mat up to
him
but the thief did not utter a word and
began to fold up the dogskin mat with
the goblin's garment into one bundle and
told his companions to paddle to the
shore the goblin went down into the hold
of the ship but soon came up with a
walking stick in his hand and pointed
with it at the canoe which was paddling
away
thunder peeled and lightning flashed but
those in the canoe paddled on
when they landed eight rows to leave the
canoe
but the thief sat still with his dog's
skin mat and the garment of the goblin
under his feet
his companions cooled to him but he did
not answer
one of them went and shook him and the
thief fell back into the hold of the
canoe and blood was seen on his clothing
and a hole in his back he was carried to
the settlement and a meeting of the
people was called to consult on the
matter at which his companions told the
tale of the theft of the goblins garment
and the people said he was the cause of
his own death and it will not be right
to avenge him
all the payment he will obtain for his
death will be the goblins garment which
he has stolen which shall be left to
bind around his body where it is laid
his body was taken and put into one of
the ancient cave burial places
not any evil came from this death and we
again went to barter with the goblins of
that ship and the goblins came again and
again on shore nor was there one evil
word spoken or any act of transgression
on our part for that death
you